We've all had good reason to feel anxious over the past two years, but sometimes anxiety is more than a normal response to stress. Anxiety disorders are among the most common of all mental health disorders, affecting an estimated 15% to 20% of all people at some point in their life. In recent years, scientists have begun to learn more about the underlying causes of these disorders, which include generalized anxiety disorder, panic disorder, and folks. such as fear of needles or flying. They've also learned more about how to treat anxiety effectively. So what ties different anxiety disorders together? Where do they come from? What's the difference between feeling anxious and that anxiety disorder? How do you know if it's time to seek help? And what effective treatments do we have for anxiety? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
在过去的两年里，我们都有充分的理由感到焦虑，但有时焦虑不仅仅是对压力的正常反应。焦虑症是所有心理健康障碍中最常见的疾病之一，据估计，15% 到 20% 的人在其一生中的某个阶段会受到影响。近年来，科学家们开始更多地了解这些疾病的潜在原因，包括广泛性焦虑症、惊恐障碍以及诸如针头恐惧症或飞行恐惧症等特定恐惧症。他们也更深入地了解了如何有效治疗焦虑症。那么，是什么将不同的焦虑症联系在一起的呢？它们从何而来？感到焦虑和患有焦虑症之间有什么区别？你怎么知道是否该寻求帮助了？我们有哪些有效的焦虑症治疗方法？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Bunmi Olatunji, director of the Emotion and Anxiety Research Lab at Vanderbilt University. Dr. Olatunji studies the role of emotions, particularly discussed, in driving anxiety symptoms and disorders. He is also interested in using the knowledge gained from basic research to develop effective treatments for anxiety disorders.
该节目探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是范德比尔特大学情绪与焦虑研究实验室主任邦米·奥拉通吉（Bunmi Olatunji）博士。奥拉通吉博士研究情绪（特别是厌恶情绪）在驱动焦虑症状和障碍中的作用。他还对利用基础研究获得的知识来开发有效的焦虑症治疗方法感兴趣。
In addition to his research, Dr. Olatunji serves as Director of Clinical Training in the Clinical Science Program in Psychological Sciences at Vanderbilt and as Associate Dean of Academic Affairs in the Graduate School. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Olatunji. Thank you so much for having me. It's a pleasure to be here with you. So we all experience anxiety at times. I think it's a familiar feeling to a lot of us, and many of us have been feeling more anxious than usual these past two years, almost two years now.
除了研究工作外，奥拉通吉博士还担任范德比尔特大学心理科学系临床科学项目的临床培训主任，以及研究生院学术事务副院长。感谢您今天参加我们的节目，奥拉通吉博士。非常感谢邀请我。很高兴能在这里与您交流。我们每个人有时都会感到焦虑。我认为这对我们许多人来说是一种熟悉的感觉，而且在过去两年，也就是将近两年里，我们许多人感到比平时更加焦虑。
what is the difference between everyday anxiety and a clinical anxiety disorder? I think that your question raises a very important point that I hope we're able to kind of get across in this conversation. And that is anxiety is an adaptive, affective process. So when we think about anxiety, we think about this as being a feeling of nervousness and apprehension in response to a perceived threat. And this can take many shapes and sizes. and the things that trigger anxiety vary for different people.
那么，日常焦虑和临床焦虑症之间有什么区别呢？我认为您的问题提出了一个非常重要的观点，我希望我们能在这次谈话中传达出来。那就是，焦虑是一种适应性的情感过程。当我们想到焦虑时，我们认为这是一种对感知到的威胁所产生的紧张和忧虑的感觉。这种感觉可以有多种形式和程度，触发焦虑的事物对不同的人来说也各不相同。
So, for example, some people's anxiety may be in response to an anticipation of a specific event. It may be in response to an intrusive thought. Or it could just be an uneasy feeling with regards to uncertainty. And those type of experiences are relatively normal. Now, when we start to think about the transition from adaptive normal anxiety into clinical anxiety, then the question really is, to what experience? extent do these experiences interfere with one's ability to function? So are these things getting in the way of our ability to have to hold a job?
例如，有些人的焦虑可能是对特定事件的预期。它可能是对侵入性想法的反应。或者它可能仅仅是对不确定性的一种不安感。这些类型的经历相对正常。现在，当我们开始考虑从适应性的正常焦虑向临床焦虑转变时，真正的问题在于：这些经历在多大程度上干扰了一个人的功能发挥？也就是说，这些事情是否阻碍了我们维持工作的能力？
Are they getting in the way of our ability to social the way that we want to? Are they interfering with our ability to function within our family systems? So really the question of whether or not these things are clinical levels of anxiety is really predicated upon the extent to which they interfere with one's ability to live the life that they want to live, right? And so how do you know that it's time to start seeking mental health treatment? Yeah, I think that that question really highlights this sort of disconnect between the experience itself and the dysfunction that's associated with it, right? And I think that for people, when they start to ask the question, well, when do I need help, right?
它们是否阻碍了我们以想要的方式进行社交的能力？它们是否干扰了我们在家庭系统中发挥作用的能力？所以，这些问题是否达到临床焦虑水平，真正取决于它们在多大程度上干扰了一个人过上他们想要的生活的能力，对吧？那么，你怎么知道是时候开始寻求心理健康治疗了呢？是的，我认为这个问题确实突出了体验本身与相关的功能障碍之间的脱节，对吧？我认为对于人们来说，当他们开始问这个问题时，也就是“我什么时候需要帮助呢？”
When should I go see a therapist? And I think that, you know, the answer that I often times give people is, when is your quality of life impacted, right? When is it the case that you're not able to have a high quality of life? And when you sort of reached that point when your quality of life is impacted, I think that's the time that's really important to go see a professional. Now, you're an expert in cognitive behavioral therapy. Can you tell us more about CBT in relation to anxiety? How does it work and how is it used to treat anxiety disorders? Yeah, so cognitive behavior therapy or CBT is really based on several sort of core principles,
“我什么时候应该去看治疗师？”我认为，我经常给人们的回答是：当你的生活质量受到影响时，对吧？当你的生活质量无法保持在高水平时。当你达到那种生活质量受到影响的程度时，我认为这就是去看专业人士的重要时刻。现在，您是认知行为疗法（CBT）方面的专家。您能告诉我们更多关于CBT与焦虑的关系吗？它是如何工作的，又是如何用于治疗焦虑症的？是的，认知行为疗法或CBT确实基于几个核心原则，
right? And so this particular therapy is largely based on the notion that anxiety disorders are based, at least in part, on faulty or dysfunctional ways of thinking, that anxiety disorders are based on learned patterns of maladaptive behavior. And so the notion here is that if we can change how people think or change the maladaptive behavior in the case of anxiety is more often than not its avoidance, if we can alter those thinking patterns and behavioral patterns, then we can help treat the anxiety disorder. Right. So that's really the underlying premise of cognitive behavior therapy, is really trying to address the cognition, the thinking patterns, and the behavior, the maladative behavior that maintain the anxiety disorders.
对吧？这种特定的疗法在很大程度上基于这样一个观念：焦虑症至少部分基于错误或功能失调的思维方式，焦虑症基于习得的适应不良行为模式。因此，这里的观点是，如果我们能改变人们的思维方式，或者改变焦虑情况下的适应不良行为（通常是回避），如果我们能改变这些思维模式和行为模式，那么我们就能帮助治疗焦虑症。没错。这就是认知行为疗法的基本前提，即真正试图解决维持焦虑症的认知、思维模式和行为（适应不良行为）。
And so when we talk about CBT and anxiety, what might that treatment look like? Particularly, say, if I have a phobia, how would you use CBT to treat that? Yeah, so with specific phobias, you know, I think the good news is that we actually have very, very efficacious, highly effective cognitive behavioral sort of interventions for phobias. And those treatments largely emphasize the process or the intervention of exposure therapy. So in the context of treating somebody who has a phobia, the approach that I would take within the umbrella of cognitive behavior therapy is implementing an exposure protocol that basically requires me to expose you to sort of elements of the things that you're afraid of.
那么，当我们谈论CBT和焦虑时，这种治疗看起来是什么样的？特别是，比如说如果我有恐惧症，你会如何使用CBT来治疗它？是的，对于特定的恐惧症，我认为好消息是我们实际上有非常有效、高效的认知行为干预措施。这些治疗在很大程度上强调暴露疗法的过程或干预。因此，在治疗患有恐惧症的人时，我在认知行为疗法框架下采取的方法是实施一种暴露方案，基本上要求我让你接触你所恐惧的事物的元素。
But we're going to do in a very gradual sense, right? So we may come up with a list, a hierarchy, if you will, of elements of the phobia that you're afraid of and kind of work our way up from the least anxiety-provoking, right? So looking at pictures or spiders to the most anxiety-provoking, having a spider crawl on your shoulder, and work our way up that hierarchy and use exposure as a way of learning to abitulate to the experience of anxiety, but also as an opportunity to learn that there is no catastrophe associated with coming into contact with the thing that you're afraid of. Now, what about medication? Are there effective medications to treat anxiety disorders?
但我们会以非常循序渐进的方式进行，对吧？所以我们可能会列出一个清单，或者说一个等级，列出你所恐惧的恐惧症元素，然后从最不引起焦虑的开始，比如看蜘蛛的图片，一直到最引起焦虑的，比如让蜘蛛爬在你的肩膀上，沿着这个等级逐步进行，并利用暴露作为一种学习习惯化于焦虑体验的方式，同时也是一个机会，让你了解到接触你所恐惧的事物并不会带来灾难性的后果。那么，药物治疗呢？有治疗焦虑症的有效药物吗？
And do you use medication in concert with CBT? Do you try one first, one second, work them together, How does that go for most people? Yeah, that's an excellent question. The medication question obviously is one that comes up quite a bit. And so it's a complicated question. So the answer is going to be equally as complicated, I'm afraid. So the short answer is that, well, yes. So there are evidence-based pharmacological interventions for anxiety and related disorders.
你是否会将药物与CBT结合使用？你是先尝试一种，再尝试另一种，还是将它们结合起来？对大多数人来说情况如何？是的，这是一个极好的问题。药物问题显然是一个经常被提及的问题。所以这是一个复杂的问题。恐怕答案也会同样复杂。简短的回答是，是的。有针对焦虑及相关疾病的循证药物干预措施。
And in most cases, some of those pharmacological agents tend to be SSRIs. Now, the question then becomes, well, how do we choose? How do we decide which one do we try? Which one do we go with first? And I think that part of that answer comes with, well, what is the comparative efficacy? So if I take my medication and I compare it to, let's say, CBT, what does the data say about outcome? And, you know, all things being equal, you know, it tends to be the case for anxiety disorders that medication and cognitive behavior therapy tend to be about comparable in their efficacy.
在大多数情况下，其中一些药物往往是SSRIs（选择性5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂）。现在的问题变成了，我们如何选择？我们如何决定尝试哪一种？我们先用哪一种？我认为答案的一部分在于，它们的比较疗效如何？如果我服用药物并将其与CBT进行比较，数据对结果有什么说明？在所有条件相同的情况下，对于焦虑症，药物和认知行为疗法在疗效上往往是相当的。
But of course, the question with the medication is, well, how does the side effects factor into your decision making about whether or not to use medication versus CBT? There's also the issue of the long-term benefits. Because with medication, more often than not, that's something that you're going to have to state. with for the long term, right? Whereas with CBT, you know, you do anywhere from 12 to 20 sessions, you have the tools and the skills, and then you're on your way. Right. So although there tends to be relatively equivalent efficacy, I think there's a different picture when we start to ask the questions about long-term effectiveness, right? Because oftentimes when you take the medication away,
但当然，关于药物的问题是，副作用如何影响你关于是否使用药物与CBT的决策？还有一个长期益处的问题。因为对于药物，通常情况下，你必须长期坚持服用，对吧？而对于CBT，你进行12到20次疗程，你就掌握了工具和技能，然后你就可以自己处理了。没错。所以虽然疗效相对相当，但我认为当我们开始询问长期有效性的问题时，情况就不同了，对吧？因为通常当你停止服药时，
what happens is that you have a lot of relapse, right? Whereas with CBT, you don't see that as much, Right? Because now the people have the skills to deal with the anxiety-related symptoms. So many people, when they think about the emotions that are associated with anxiety, they think about fear, and I know you mentioned that earlier. But your research focuses a lot on a different emotion, disgust. Let's talk about that. What's the connection between disgust and anxiety? Yeah. So our interest in the emotion of disgust, you know, is largely, a result of listening to our patients, right? And when you think about a disorder like obsessive compulsive disorder, for example, or even spider phobia, or individuals who may be
会发生什么呢？你会经历很多复发，对吧？而对于CBT，你不会看到那么多复发，对吧？因为现在人们有了应对焦虑相关症状的技能。所以许多人在想到与焦虑相关的情绪时，会想到恐惧，我知道你之前提到过这一点。但你的研究更多地关注另一种情绪：厌恶。让我们谈谈这个。厌恶和焦虑之间有什么联系？是的。我们对厌恶情绪的兴趣，在很大程度上是倾听患者的结果。当你想到强迫症（OCD）这样的疾病，或者蜘蛛恐惧症，或者那些可能
phobic of blood needles, injections, and things of that sort, you know, it became clear to us that there's a large majority of those patients, and OCD, I think, is a good example, especially with patients who have sort of contamination concerns, that a lot of those patients, kind of describe the distress associated with their symptoms as one of disgust and not fear. So the language that they oftentimes use is really this notion of, you know, I'm not really afraid of it, but it certainly grosses me out, and I just cannot handle that, right? So in the language, they're really describing a different affective process that they're experiencing. And so we've been really interested in really trying to figure out, well, is this distinction that
对血液、针头、注射等感到恐惧的人时，我们清楚地发现，很大一部分患者（我认为强迫症是一个很好的例子，特别是那些有污染担忧的患者）将与症状相关的痛苦描述为厌恶而非恐惧。他们经常使用的语言是：“我并不是真的害怕它，但它确实让我感到恶心，我无法忍受。”所以，在语言上，他们实际上是在描述他们正在经历的一种不同的情感过程。因此，我们一直非常有兴趣弄清楚，他们所做的这种区分
they're making? Is it a meaningful one? And does that really tell us anything different about the prognosis of their illness? Let's talk for a minute about needle phobia, which is something that's been very much in the news of late because everybody is, or at least we hope everybody is getting vaccines. How do you use CBT to treat needle phobia? I mean, are you giving people bogus injections? I mean, an injection is an injection. So how do you desensitize people to that? So the question of, you know, how do we use CBT to treat blood injection injury phobia? The good news is that the data that we have on the exposure-based approaches to treating that particular phobia is really quite impressive. So much so that there are, in fact, treatment protocols that, you know, within three to five
是否有意义？这是否真的告诉我们关于疾病预后的任何不同信息？让我们花点时间谈谈针头恐惧症，这在最近的新闻中非常多见，因为每个人都在（或者我们希望每个人都在）接种疫苗。你如何使用CBT来治疗针头恐惧症？你是给人们进行虚假的注射吗？注射就是注射。那么你如何让人们对它脱敏呢？关于我们如何使用CBT来治疗血液-注射-损伤恐惧症的问题，好消息是我们拥有的关于治疗该特定恐惧症的基于暴露的方法的数据确实非常令人印象深刻。以至于事实上，有治疗方案可以在三到五
hours of treating somebody, you can actually get pretty good effects. So this can be something that if a person was committed to, they can overcome, in a day of intensive therapy. So to your question about what exactly does the therapy actually look like from an exposure standpoint, well, again, you know, so we very well may start from looking at pictures of injections and then working our way up, looking at videos, maybe taking a trip over to the Red Cross and observing and maybe putting a needle right up to the arm. So there are things that we can do in a very hierarchical way to, A, facilitate this notion of
小时内就能产生相当不错的效果。所以如果一个人下定决心，他们可以在一天的强化治疗中克服它。关于治疗从暴露的角度来看究竟是什么样子的，同样，我们很可能会从看注射图片开始，然后逐步进行，看视频，也许去红十字会观察，也许把针头直接靠近手臂。所以我们可以以一种非常分级的方式做一些事情，A，促进这种习惯化的概念，
habituation, right, to get the person to abituate to their anxiety, but also to kind of use those really, those exposure items as we are sort of engaging in some corrective learning, right? So nothing catastrophic is going to happen. Now, of course, we do have the issue of fainting, right? That's a very common thing that happens with people who are phobic of needles. So the vasovagal sort of syncope response is a very common thing. And what's really interesting is that there have been some modifications as to the exposure protocols that they can also effectively treat individuals who have sort of this fainting response. And that is often referred to as the applied tension technique. So within the context of doing the exposure work,
对吧，让人们习惯于他们的焦虑，同时也利用这些暴露项目进行一些纠正性学习，对吧？即不会发生任何灾难性的事情。当然，我们确实面临昏厥的问题，对吧？这在针头恐惧症患者中是非常普遍的。所以血管迷走性晕厥反应是非常常见的。非常有趣的是，暴露方案已经进行了一些修改，可以有效地治疗那些有这种昏厥反应的个体。这通常被称为应用张力技术。因此，在进行暴露工作的过程中，
if you're having patients who have sort of fainting symptoms also engage in some applied muscle tension, right? That actually helps to suppress the fainting response, right? So then they can fully benefit from the exposure work. So there's actually very good evidence-based work out there for individuals who may have that fear who want to get vaccinated. You know, they can actually be effectively treated fairly quickly so they can do that. For many people, the COVID-19 pandemic has been. a major cause of anxiety over the last almost two years. And you've been doing some research on anxiety during the pandemic. Can you talk about that? What is it that you're seeing? And is there
如果你的患者有昏厥症状，也可以让他们进行一些应用肌肉张力训练，对吧？这实际上有助于抑制昏厥反应，对吧？这样他们就能从暴露工作中充分受益。所以对于那些可能有这种恐惧但想要接种疫苗的人来说，确实有非常好的循证工作。他们实际上可以相当快地得到有效治疗，这样他们就可以做到这一点。对于许多人来说，COVID-19大流行在过去近两年里一直是焦虑的主要原因。你一直在做关于大流行期间焦虑的研究。你能谈谈吗？你看到了什么？是否有
indeed a measurable increase? Yeah, I think that there is a measurable increase in anxiety symptoms over the time course of the pandemic. And of course, part of the challenge for us as clinical scientists is really trying to conceptualize, well, how much of that is normative, is adaptive, right? Because the truth is, you know, we are sort of in this context of uncertainty. We're in this context of uncontrollability. We're in this context of unpredictability, right? So their new variants are coming out at rates that we can often predict. And that's, you know, the uncertainty, the uncontrollability and the unpredictability is sort of a context in which anxiety tends to manifest. So those are sort of the building blocks, if you will, for people to experience
确实可测量的增加？是的，我认为在大流行期间焦虑症状确实有可测量的增加。当然，作为临床科学家，我们面临的挑战之一是真正试图概念化：其中有多少是规范的、适应性的？因为事实是，我们处于这种不确定性的环境中。我们处于这种不可控的环境中。我们处于这种不可预测的环境中，对吧？所以新的变异株以我们往往无法预测的速度出现。这种不确定性、不可控性和不可预测性是焦虑往往表现出来的环境。所以这些是人们经历焦虑的基石，
anxiety. So some of the increase that we're seeing during the pandemic really should be expected and sort of is what would be predicted, right? Some of that is adaptive. But within that, we are seeing, you know, a certain percentage of individuals who were already at risk to begin with, right? So they had various risk factors. And this is just the stressor that sort of makes those risk factors manifest. So we are seeing an uptick, if you will, not only adaptive anxiety, but also clinical levels of anxiety. But again, some of that is to be expected, given the context that we're in. When you say adaptive anxiety, what exactly do you mean by that?
对吧？所以我们在大流行期间看到的一些增加确实是可以预期的，也是可以预测的，对吧？其中一些是适应性的。但在其中，我们确实看到了一定比例的个体，他们本来就处于风险之中，对吧？他们有各种风险因素。而这只是使这些风险因素显现出来的压力源。所以我们看到的不仅是适应性焦虑的增加，还有临床水平焦虑的增加。但同样，考虑到我们所处的环境，其中一些是可以预期的。当你提到适应性焦虑时，你具体指的是什么？
Well, I think we would agree that anxiety can also motivate problem solving, right? And so for a lot of people, the anxiety motivates them to socially distance. It motivates them to make sure that they have their mask candy. And so some of that anxiety that we're feeling, or they were, seeing is adaptive in the sense that it's motivating us to do the things that we need to do to keep us safe. So it's not always a bad thing sometimes. No, it's not always a bad thing.
嗯，我想我们会同意焦虑也可以激励解决问题，对吧？对于许多人来说，焦虑激励他们保持社交距离。它激励他们确保随身携带口罩。所以我们感受到或看到的这种焦虑，在某种意义上是适应性的，因为它激励我们去做我们需要做的事情来保持安全。所以它有时并不总是一件坏事。不，它并不总是一件坏事。
I think I would be more concerned about the absence of some anxiety. So what got you interested in studying anxiety in specific? Are you an anxious guy? Well, I don't think so. Not terribly so. Well, you know, my graduate school advisor, Dr. Jeffrey Lohr, who unfortunately passed away this year, this was sort of his bread and butter, right? So this was something that he was sort of very interested in and studied quite extensively.
我想如果完全没有焦虑，我反而会更担心。是什么让你对研究焦虑产生了兴趣？你是一个焦虑的人吗？嗯，我不这么认为。不是特别焦虑。嗯，你知道，我的研究生导师杰弗里·洛尔（Jeffrey Lohr）博士，不幸的是他今年去世了，这是他的专长，对吧？所以这是他非常感兴趣并进行了广泛研究的课题。
And he was really the one that kind of opened my eyes at this question of disgust and anxiety and how do we sort of fit this emotion into the clinical picture. And, you know, when I first started, you know, really working in this area back in 2000, there really wasn't any research undiscussed within the context of anxiety pathology. So he was really working in his lab and trying to figure out this new piece of the anxiety puzzle, this question of discuss, then that then motivated me to start thinking about other things, like just in terms of, you know, what are the evidence-based therapies for anxiety disorders? How do we implement those?
他确实是那个让我开始关注厌恶和焦虑这个问题，以及我们如何将这种情绪融入临床图景的人。而且，当我刚开始在2000年左右真正从事这个领域的工作时，在焦虑病理学的背景下，确实没有任何关于厌恶的研究。所以他当时在实验室里努力工作，试图弄清楚焦虑拼图的这一新部分，即厌恶的问题，这随后激励我开始思考其他事情，比如关于焦虑症的循证疗法是什么？我们如何实施这些疗法？
What are some questions with regards to dissemination of these therapies? So it was really that basic work in graduate school that really motivated me to start asking some of these other questions about anxiety-related psychopathology. So what are the next big questions for you? What are you working on? Where do you hope to go with this? You know, for myself and sort of as a field, there's several areas where I think that we still need to do much better work.
关于这些疗法的传播有哪些问题？所以正是研究生阶段的基础工作真正激励我开始提出关于焦虑相关精神病理学的其他问题。那么你接下来的重大问题是什么？你正在研究什么？你希望在这方面取得什么进展？对于我自己以及整个领域来说，我认为我们仍然需要在几个方面做得更好。
So Coggy Beaver therapy is a highly efficacious. treatment. And I think that most people would agree that it's kind of the best psychological treatment that we have. But that being said, not everybody benefits from this therapy. And for those that do benefit, we oftentimes see a relapse or a return of symptoms. So our therapy is good, but it's clearly not great. And so I think that's one of the areas where we really need to sort of figure out what are the factors even before somebody starts therapy that can tell us who's really going to benefit? And for those who we know beforehand, they're not going to fully benefit, well, what do we do with those individuals? How do we help those individuals? So this question of
认知行为疗法是一种高效的治疗方法。我认为大多数人会同意它是我们拥有的最好的心理治疗方法。但话虽如此，并非每个人都能从这种疗法中受益。对于那些确实受益的人，我们经常看到复发或症状回归。所以我们的疗法很好，但显然还不够好。所以我认为这是我们需要弄清楚的领域之一，即在某人开始治疗之前，有哪些因素可以告诉我们谁真正会受益？对于那些我们预先知道不会完全受益的人，我们该怎么办？我们如何帮助这些人？所以这个问题，
prognostic indicators, I think is a really important question moving forward. Similarly, you know, I think the question of kind of going back to your question about medication, you know, I do think that medication can be a good therapy for some people, but not for everyone. And I think the question is, you know, what are the prescriptive indicators? That is, what are the things that I can have in my hands before a person starts therapy that will tell me, oh, you know what? Given these factors, that person should get cognitive therapy or given these factors, that person really should get medication. So having these prognostic and prescriptive indicators and then trying to figure out how do we implement them and trying to figure out who's going to benefit even before they start, I think is a really important future direction. The other area is just one of dissemination, right?
预后指标，我认为是未来一个非常重要的问题。同样，我认为回到你关于药物的问题，我确实认为药物对某些人来说可能是一种很好的疗法，但并非对每个人都适用。我认为问题在于，什么是处方指标？也就是说，在一个人开始治疗之前，我手中可以掌握哪些东西能告诉我：“哦，你知道吗？考虑到这些因素，那个人应该接受认知疗法，或者考虑到这些因素，那个人确实应该接受药物治疗。”所以拥有这些预后和处方指标，然后试图弄清楚我们如何实施它们，并试图在他们开始之前就弄清楚谁会受益，我认为是一个非常重要的未来方向。另一个领域是传播问题，对吧？
I mean, we have this good therapy, but not everyone has access to it, right? Not everyone can afford it. And I think these issues of, you know, that question is kind of a larger question just in terms of our health care system. system, right? But really giving people access to this therapy, I think is really that sort of the next frontiers. How do we get this out there to the masses so people can access it? Well, Dr. Olatunji, this has been really interesting. I hope our listeners have found some of this helpful. I appreciate you joining us today. Thank you. Well, thank you for your time. I really enjoyed it. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeatingof
我的意思是，我们有这种好的疗法，但并非每个人都能获得它，对吧？并非每个人都能负担得起。我认为这些问题，那个问题在我们的医疗保健系统方面是一个更大的问题，对吧？但真正让人们获得这种疗法，我认为这确实是下一个前沿。我们如何将其推广给大众，以便人们能够获得它？好吧，奥拉通吉博士，这真的非常有趣。我希望我们的听众觉得其中一些内容有帮助。感谢您今天参加我们的节目。谢谢。好吧，谢谢你的时间。我真的很享受。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingof
psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. And where it's possible, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening.
psychology.org 或在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果可能的话，请给我们留下评论。如果你有关于未来播客的评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，连在一起，at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·威纳曼（Lee Winerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩（Chris Condyenne）。感谢收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim. Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。